hello everyone and the happy Women's Day
to all of my 2.9% of women viewers I
hope you're all having a great today and
an interesting fact to go with that on
this day in 1942 the world lost one of
its one of its greatest chess players
ever of course I'm talking about the
great Cuban Jose kappa blanka now that
getting that out of the way let's start
with our fourth game of the 1960 World
Chess Championship match Michael towel
versus Mikhail Botvinnik I think I
should elaborate the title of the video
as and also this also refers to the
quote above the board the reason both of
it is the way it is is towel always had
this habit of leaving the hotel room
like 15 minutes before the game starts
and this time before game 4 started
target into a lot of fights with the
traffic lights as they got a taxi and
they had this huge wave of red lights
and tal was trying to explain to the
taxi driver that he's actually playing
Mikhail Botvinnik for the title of
Rogers champion and he tried to convince
the taxi driver that maybe he should
break some of the rules just to get
there a little bit faster as he doesn't
want to be late for his game against
Botvinnik but the taxi driver wasn't
much of a chess player nor was he
impressed and so tile was late for game
number 4 so when he arrived he already
had bought Phoenix first move on the
board and the move was v4 and this also
refers to the part about the board tall
doesn't understand what's Bronstein
doing for like 10 to 30 minutes I even
had one game where Bronstein was
thinking for over 50 minutes for his
first move because this flew through
Todd's mind as he was already late and
for the game he had to make his move so
he couldn't really imagine why would
anyone think so long for the first move
but ok he got here and now what's the
play and it's very interesting because
it all says that you know a chess match
can be divided into two stages you have
four four half of the match you have the
white pieces for help do you have the
black pieces and when you have the white
pieces you want to get full points but
when you have the black pieces you're
kind of satisfied it would be equality
but didn't really think that he could
maintain his one-point lead
the entire match I thought that there
wasn't really any point in trying to
draw all the games against Botvinnik for
the rest of the match as the positions
that would arise out of drawn openings
would definitely favor me how Botvinnik
and at some point both Munich would
definitely win at least one game
so I thought that he would definitely
have to take some chances and he thought
about a lot of things and he decided
that it was time for a nice nimzo-indian
game so 92f 6 tall thought that if he
tried what he already played against
about to neaten game number two with the
black pieces and that Botvinnik would
probably win that game as a style says
that he did have some luck in game
number two and although the game was
drawn it was basically basically a win
for both minik so 90 to f6 we have c4 e6
and now Knight to c3 and Bishop to b4 so
we have the nimzo-indian
and here a3 was played Bishop captures
on c3 he captures on c3 and here we have
castles by tau FAL says that c5 is
definitely an interesting move but Micah
botanique had so much success playing
against c5 throughout his career
there's his win against donor were over
black plays c5 and there's the most
famous when out of all probably bought
in of his games where kappa blanka
played c5 in their famous match in Avro
in 1938 and he totally obliterated
capablanca with the white pieces I did a
cover this game at one point if I find
the leak I will put it in the
description below
so tau doesn't like the idea of playing
c5 here he castles we had f3 botanique
now goes for the semi variation which
was expected
he immediately wants to push f4 and grab
the center and of course
dolls next move is d5 he doesn't allow
it and here C captures on d5 is played
and this is what I really enjoy you can
really see how much home preparation
called this 2x to even be able to face
bottom it over the board because style
now in this position knows that III
isn't really a good move because there
is another famous game where Botvinnik
was playing with the black pieces
against
lilienthal all under
lilienthal and her lilienthal played III
and Botvinnik really got a terrific game
with black against that so seek after
sandy five by botanique he captures on
d5 and now III and here Thal says that
White's plan is pretty simple here
playing c5 here would transpose into
bottoming the game would Capablanca so
he doesn't want to play that but he says
that White's plan is put pretty clear
Bishop to d3 night is coming to e 2
followed by g4 followed by Knight to g3
and at some point if black allows it
this night will help white pull this
point to e4 and white will have an
excellent game that will eventually turn
into an attack on the black King so he
definitely doesn't want to allow that he
plays Bishop to a5 now controlling the
Foursquare and waiting for botanique and
also Bishop to f5 is kind of setting a
trap for black but the Botany doesn't
fall for it the idea is that if white
goes for g4 immediately then Todd can
simply capture Knight captures on g4
pawn captures and now Queen to h4 check
King b2 and now Bishop to e4 attacking
the undefended rock on h1
Knight to f3 only way to block this and
now Queen to have to check whatever y2
does if he blocks with the bishop then
the bishop is pinned y can simply
capture the knight on f3 and if it walks
with the Queen then simply but should
capture Queen captures on f3 white brick
gets the piece back and keeps an extra
pawn so after Bishop e5 Knight the e2 is
coming and now we had Knight B to d7 and
this Knight B to d7 is also an excellent
home preparation by tau as the there is
a famous game where white continued
actually to play g4 now because now
white thought that he played Knight to
e2 it's okay to play g4 but not really
this Knight the d7 move by tau is
explicitly played to stop g4 because now
if we play d4 black will nevertheless
capture on g4 and after F captures Queen
to h4 check King to d2 and now Bishop to
e4 check bishop T for attacking the roof
that is undefended rook the g1 and now
Knight to b6 and now you can see the
bishop is slicing all the way
here the skin doesn't really have
anywhere to go Queen is covering a one
and night the Seaforth chick is a
terrible threat so in that famous game
c4 was played and the black won that
game very easily the move you have to
find for white if you want to play a
position like this is rook to g3 simply
preventing a queen from blocking a1 and
allow Knight to c4 check run with the
king to e1 but even if this position
would be playable for it for an engine I
don't think a human could play this with
the white pieces so Botvinnik of course
isn't interested in any complications he
simply plays Knight g3 attacks the
Bishop Bishop to g6 and now Bishop to d3
tall doesn't mind this at this idea that
the bishops are facing each other he
pushes c5 we have castles Bible tunic
and now rook to e8 rook to e1 and here
tal says that of course the rook would
be very helpful on the F file but if
bottoming he's ever hoping to push efore
he does need the help of the rook Queen
to c7 and now worship characters on g6
that says that maybe not capturing the
bishop and pushing e4 immediately would
favor white more but both Vinick likes
simplifications here Bishop captures HP
after Sun g4 end now
efore we had captures on d4 captures on
d4 and now rook the c8 and here both
players pretty much achieved their
opening goals Botvinnik was able to push
efore towel was able to take control of
the C file but tal says himself that in
this position he prefers white very much
Bishop to g5 by botanique if I was also
an option but what Vinick wanted wants
to exchange this bishop for the night as
because the default pawn is fixed he
doesn't really see the use of his dark
square bishop
so Queen to c2 and now Bishop captures
on f6 and here's a very interesting
insight in how a grandmaster things here
pretty much every one of us would
probably play Knight captures on f6 I
don't know maybe if you really study the
position you would come to different
conclusions because you like your queen
and c2 you you want your quintessence e2
if white captures that you get your rook
see - this comes for free but tall
actually doesn't like this he says that
if he plays nine characters on f6 that
Queen characters on c2 would actually be
favorable for white sorry that after E 5
and Knight comes to d7 that now Queen
captures on c2 would be favorable for
white because after rook captures now
you have rook to d1 attacking the b7
point 96 now a for threatening to
dislodge the night and after rook to e7
you have to guard the b7 pawn now white
would have the option of playing Knight
to f1 and he would be threatening night
to e3 which attempt on the rook that's
on c2 a 5 would be a threat and Knight
from e3 will also pick up the d5 pawn so
a lot of things to consider here you
know really a lot of things to consider
when you were playing on a level like
this
so instead tell plays a Queen captures
on d1 rook capture Sunday one and only
now Knight captures on f6 he also did
consider G captures on f6 given up the
d5 pawn but after pawn captures white is
up a pawn but it's unlikely that any
player could make any progress here
so tau keeps all the material equal
Knight captures on f6e 5 and now Knight
to h5 here tall basically offers a draw
because if you exchange knights you go
into a rock sending I mean that's
unlikely that you're gonna win this
another thing is tal really didn't like
the move Knight to d7 because after
Knight to d7 again rook the b1 is coming
and after night comes here a4 and you
pretty much have the same idea without
the extra tempo was black rook and c2 9
F 193 going for the d5 pawn so thought L
really didn't like this so he played
nice to h5 and he says botanique was
really low on time here he had to make a
choice that's human to draw capture the
knight or does he want to play this game
on botany he decided he wants to play on
Knight to e2 and now rook to c2 da da no
gets a very active rock but it's
interesting that although the rook is
all the way on c2 it's really not all
that active
as botanique plays King to f1 and now
what's this rook really doing uncie to
g5 now this was a much-needed move there
was no time to activate the other look
on the C file because botanique was
threatening g4 to capture the night now
that the top like g5 day there is an
outpost for the night and f4 so rug D 2
c1 offering to exchange one pair of
crooks but now rookie to c8 and now G 3
g3 is an excellent move by Botvinnik so
says stall some some commentators have
said that a better idea was to capture
on C to bring the other roof to be one
and then to be 5 to go for the d5 pawn
but tal says they have no idea what
they're talking about
so g3 not allowing this night any
movement now this Knight can't be
activated and it's pretty stranded there
on h5 Talos f6 we have rook captures and
c2 rook captures and c2 and rook to be
one and although don't need it to make
something happen here he needs to play
f6 maybe g6 get this Knight back into
the game but now he does have some
problems
he plays b6 not allowing the rook to
capture it and now rook to b5 and now
his D pawn is attacked pawn captures
pawn captures and now rook to c5 pretty
much the only move you not want white to
capture the d5 pawn and now we have
night to d4 botanique now guards the
rook King comes to f7
kingi - and now g6 finally tall we'll be
able to bring this rook back into a
knight back into the game King D 3 9 IG
7 rock back to be one and now rook to a
five-night the C to protecting the pawn
now Knight comes to e6 qing-er looked
before
rook back to c5 and now h 4 and here now
really this only gives tall the
opportunity to fix his pawns so G
captures rook captures and now
d4 what's this d4 move that basically
forces the game into a draw because now
rook to c3 is a terrible threat
so the point must be captured
might capture some d4 rook captures on
e5 and here Knight captors on e6 King
captors on e6 and here we have a four
rook to g5 and here rook to e4 and this
is move 40 bottoming just played move 40
and here tile suggested that the game
should be drawn but nevertheless
botanique a style to make a move and
then he will consider it and it's
interesting that it doesn't matter what
moved out place here it will still be a
draw but also it's probably some some
kind of psychological warfare by
botanique that make tile make a move
here top play King to f6 and they agreed
to a draw so a very interesting game and
you can you can really see how much
preparation went into this game so if I
play this this was already played if I
played that that was already played I
don't want to play this you know how to
play that so it's really tallis talis
leading by one point because of that
nice win in Game one but still it's like
going through a minefield every move is
a game but when you probably already
want a great brilliance in so I can
really imagine how I mean I can't even
imagine what what tal went through
playing botanique here but yeah that's
the game number four I do hope you
enjoyed it and let's just I did prepare
one photo for you guys here it is you
can see it all on the Left plane both
weak on the right it's a photo from this
match
I don't really know in which game this
photo was taken but it doesn't really
matter I don't really have that much
photos to show one in every game but I
will show this or that one here and then
so yeah now we can marvel at it for for
a while and yeah I do hope you enjoy
this game as usual you can check two of
my previous videos here I would like to
thank Joshua Billy for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon with Game five of the 1960
Watchers championship match thank you
all and I will see you soon